thank you very much thank you
we're here today to provide an update on
the unprecedented testing capacity
developed by the United States the most
advanced and robust testing system
anywhere in the world by far this
afternoon I'll also announced new steps
that we're taking to make tests even
more widely available to battle a virus
my administration marshaled every
resource at our nation's disposal public
private military economic scientific and
industrial all at your disposal we
launched the largest manufacturing
ramped up since the Second World War
there's been nothing like it since at
the center of this industrial and
scientific mobilization was the
development of our corona virus testing
capabilities in the span of just a few
short months we've developed a testing
capacity unmatched and unrivaled
anywhere in the world and it's not even
close this is a core element of our plan
to safely and gradually reopen America
and we're opening and we're starting and
there's enthusiasm like I haven't seen
in a long time every American should be
proud of the amazing array of talent
skill and enterprise our nation is
brought to this challenge in three
months the FDA has authorized more than
92 different tests and over nine million
have been performed here in the United
States three weeks ago we were
conducting roughly 150,000 tests per day
now we're doing approximately 300,000
tests per day a 100% increase and it
will go up substantially from that
number this week the United States will
pass 10 million tests conducted nearly
double the number of any other country
we're testing more people per capita
than South Korea the United Kingdom
France Japan Sweden Finland Finland and
many other countries and in some cases
combined on Friday the FDA authorized
coronavirus antigen test an alternative
testing technique
that can be much more readily
manufactured qui dell corporation which
makes this newly authorized
point-of-care test estimates that it
will be able to manufacture 150 thousand
tests per day immediately increasing to
three hundred thousand tests per day
within just a few weeks to further
expand our nation's testing capabilities
this afternoon I am announcing that my
administration is in and we've got this
all approved that's all done is sending
1 billion dollars to America's States
territories and tribes so this has all
been approved we've gotten it done
completed the money is going out this
major investment will ensure that
America continues to conduct more tests
than any country on earth by far I said
from the beginning that the federal
government would back up the states and
help them build their testing capability
and capacities and that's exactly what's
happened this partnership has truly
flourished we have really had a very
good relationship with the states and
the governor's and other representatives
within the States a relationship like I
think I can honestly say has not been
seen in this country for many many years
the governors and us are working
together very closely not only in
testing but on ventilators where we have
a capacity that's at this point
virtually unlimited and we're sending
ventilators as you probably heard from
other countries we're sending many many
thousands of ventilators to other
countries because they're in tremendous
need and I think building up a lot of
goodwill but much more importantly than
that we're saving a lot of lives most
states are now doing a great job my
administration located 5,000 machines
and 700 labs across all 50 states and
governors have learned how to maximize
these testing resources the federal
government is also supporting States
with vital supplies quick approvals of
new tests and one-on-one coaching from
the team here at the White House on how
to increase capacity and increase it
very quickly in recent weeks we've held
multiple conference calls with every
state
as well as with DC and Puerto Rico we
jointly develop testing projections and
goals for each state for the month of
May all together totaling 12 point 9
million tests think of that 12 point 9
million tests today I'm announcing that
my administration will provide the
collection supplies to help States meet
their targets and meet them rapidly
during the month of May FEMA and HHS
will be delivering twelve point nine
million swabs to States nationwide we
already have them the delivery will be
very quick we're prepared to provide
millions of additional swabs if any
state is on a pace to surpass its goal
and their goals are very high we've set
them very high we've told them to set
them very high my administration will
also provide approximately nine million
transport media which are used to
transfer swabs to the lab processing a
complicated process but we've made it
simple as a result of these actions
every single state will be able to test
more people per capita in May alone then
South Korea has tested in four months
since the outbreak began this major
commitment is possible because of the
massive mobilization of American
industry including puritan medical
products u.s. cotton Abbott Labs and
thermo Fisher some of these incredible
companies produced sand produce rapidly
for us and their products are here with
us this afternoon these are all
different products that were literally
just developed and if you can imagine
that and these are the best machines and
the best equipment anywhere in the world
and other countries are calling us and
we're trying to work as much as we can
not only on ventilators but also with
testing my administration also continues
our tireless effort to expand testing in
the most underserved communities through
our partnership with the private sector
leading pharmacies and retailers are now
operating over 240 testing sites across
the country and that's in addition to
all of the other sites that we have
working 70 percent of these sites are
located in communities with unique
vulnerabilities there will be more than
300 sites by the end of
this week and retailers are making plans
to open up hundreds and hundreds more
locations within the next 30 days these
additional sites are helping us ensure
access to testing in every community
my administration is fighting
relentlessly to protect all citizens of
every color and Creed from this terrible
virus the invisible enemy in addition to
vast amounts of testing supplies my
administration is partnered with the
private sector to coordinate the
delivery of more than 90 million n95
masks and these are of the highest
quality many are made right here in the
United States and capacity we didn't
have it all at the beginning 126 million
surgical masks likewise many are made
here nine million face shields 21
million surgical gowns nine hundred
ninety three million gloves and ten
thousand six hundred ninety ventilators
who are building thousands of
ventilators in numerous plants all
across our country it's incredible
actually this global pandemic has
inflicted great pain and hardship on our
people it should have never been allowed
to happen it should have been stopped at
the source
we mourn for every life the virus has
claimed and we share the grief of all of
the you who've lost a loved one and that
goes worldwide to many many countries
184 countries at least thanks to the
courage of our citizens and our
aggressive strategy hundreds of
thousands of lives have been saved and
we have saved and if you look at on a
per 100,000 basis we're at the best part
of the pack right on the bottom Germany
and us are leading the world Germany and
the United States are leading the world
live saved per hundred thousand in a
regeneration through every challenge and
hardship and danger America has risen to
the task we have met the moment and we
have prevailed Americans do whatever it
takes to find solutions pioneer
breakthroughs and harness the energies
we need to achieve a total victory day
after day we're making tremendous
strides with the dedication of our
doctors and nurses these are incredible
people these are brave people these are
warriors with the devotion of our
manufacturing workers food suppliers and
lab technicians and with the profound
patriotism of the American people we
will defeat this horrible enemy we will
revive our economy and we will
transition into greatness that's a
phrase you're going to hear a lot
because that's what's going to happen
we're going into the third quarter and
we're going to do well in the fourth
quarter we're going to do very good and
next year I think we're gonna have one
of the best years we've ever had because
there's a tremendous pent up demand it's
a demand and I'm feeling it I've felt
things alot over in my life and I've
made a lot of good calls it's a demand
like I don't think I've ever seen
there's a pent-up demand there's a
there's a spirit in this country like
few have seen and I think you can say
and we've helped a lot of the countries
a lot really a lot there's a tremendous
spirit all over the world to beat this
terrible terrible thing but we're
transitioning to greatness and the
greatness is going to be in a fourth
quarter but it's really going to be next
year and it's going to be year like
we've never had before I really believe
that as good as we've done and we've
done great we had the best economy in
the history of the world not just here
but anywhere in the world you can talk
jaina you can talk any other country we
had the best economy anywhere in the
world and we were going for numbers
weather was unemployment numbers well we
had our best numbers employment also
numbers a little different where we had
our best numbers almost a hundred and
sixty million people all of that we had
the greatest stock market numbers ever I
think we're hundred and forty-two days
where we set records in a short period
of time 152 days we set records in the
stock market we rebuilt our military all
built in the United States all of our
equipment built one point five trillion
dollars plus on the southern border the
wall is being built it's being built
rapidly and now you
don't hear the opponents talking too
much about the border they don't like to
talk about it because it seemed that we
were right on a lot of things one of the
things we were right about one of the
many things was the border we have a
very powerful border now we had one of
the best weeks in the history of our
border between the United States and
Mexico our southern border we had very
few people coming in very very few
almost record low numbers and the wall
is being built it's up to 181 miles
already it's being built it's being
built rapidly people don't talk about it
anymore because it's very successful in
the area where the wall has built that
is a lot still but we want to be up to
450 by very short period of time early
next year we should be up to 450 and
very shortly after that over 500 miles
to be completed but it's had a
tremendous impact but again we've had
the best numbers the last thing we want
now with this pandemic is for people to
come across our southern border and
again we're doing record numbers meaning
record low numbers
so I just want to thank everybody and I
want to introduce Admiral guar if you
could please come up and bread if you
would bread Smith and they're going to
do a little explaining as to what we've
done with regard to testing and how
successful it's been and then we'll take
some questions after that thank you very
much well thank you mr. president for
your leadership and for your high
expectations that really made this all
come together and for the uniform
support of everyone in the White House
and the administration and Thank You
secretary azar for providing his
leadership at HHS and allowing both Brad
and I the opportunity to work on this
project I think it's clear that America
does lead the world in testing I'll go
through some of the charts that show
that we lead quantitatively I will also
suggest that we lead in the diversity of
tests which are very important to
establish the testing ecosystem to keep
America safe and clearly as we've said
multiple times no one beats America when
it comes to quality so
start potentially with the next slide
this may be hard to see but if you look
at the line on top that's the total
numbers of tests done by the United
States no other country in the world
comes close to the total numbers again
as the president has said today we will
top over 9 million tests and if you look
at per capita everyone talks about South
Korea being the standard today we will
have done more than twice their per
capita rate of testing that was
accomplished in South Korea no matter
how you look at it America is leading
the world in testing and how did we get
there let's look at the next slide next
slide please a very important component
of how we came to this point was the
authorization by the FDA under the
leadership of our secretary of many
different diagnostic tests of diagnostic
devices and now of serology tests so
you've heard a lot about the different
testing and you see some of the machines
up here most of the diagnostic tests all
but one rely on the amplification of the
viral RNA the viral nucleic material and
we've talked to you about the diversity
of tests they're very high throughput
tests that are done at big reference
labs like LabCorp and quest but very
importantly there are also tests and you
heard us talk about Cepheid delivering
over 2 million tests vitally important
to rural americas and to places that do
not have very large infrastructure
you've also seen the Abbott test we've
talked about there it is on the left of
the president delivering about 1.4
million tests as a point of care test
you get the result within 5 to 15
minutes and we have deployed over 235
thousand of these tests to the state
public health laboratories in every
state of this country to make sure that
that point of care testing capability is
there to research outbreaks like in
nursing homes or in certain industrial
capacity
and well over 90,000 to the Indian
Health Service so they could test at a
point of care in remote locations the
president also talked about a new first
in-class test it's listed there as an
antigen based test this is very
important and you've heard ambassador
birx talk about this multiple times
because antigen testing although complex
is much less complex than the nucleic
acid testing that we've had Cadell had
this authorized by the fda and as the
president said we'll soon be making over
300,000 tests per day do the math that's
nine million point-of-care tests that we
will have every month in just a few
weeks it will clearly add to into a
certain degree transform our landscape
which you don't see up here is the
important work the FDA did I'm a swab
guy now I'm very interested in swabs in
order to make all these tests work you
have to show that a certain swab made of
a certain material performed in a
certain way delivers a highly accurate
result and what you're seeing up here is
some of the fruits of that labor without
the authorizations of for example the
foam nasal swab we would be blowing
through PPE all across the country
because of the need for full PPE just to
take a test that has really been changed
by this diverse authorization and a
recent authorization allows the great
manufacturer u.s. cotton to join our
foundational injury industry of puritan
next slide
last week we did over 1.9 million tests
and that number is growing and again as
the president said and Brad will talk
about our state's aspired to do well
over 12 million tests over the next four
weeks you see the graph growing which
you also see very importantly is that
little orange bar on the bottom is the
cumulative number of positives our
percent positives are going down and
that's what we want to see in fact in 31
States as of last night the positivity
rate is less than 10% which is not a
litmus test but it is a good idea that
we're doing plenty enough testing that
we can enter phase 1 for careful
reopening I also want to take the
opportunity to say this
doesn't happen by accident I'm seeing
everyone in the audience here and I'm so
pleased that they can be here people
sitting in the front have been working
literally 18 to 20 hours a day every
single day of the week for at least the
past two months
none of this happens by accident it
happens because their hard work their
sacrifice their sacrifice of their
family all for a common good and I'm
very very honored to consider to you all
as my colleagues in my last slide as the
president said 11 billion dollars are
now being announced to be delivered to
the States for the sole support of
testing this will give them the
resources to partner as they have with
the federal government with the
president the vice-president the task
force with Brad and I to achieve their
testing goals and we're gonna be very
specific and they know it
that there needs to be minimum numbers
to be planned to test they have to have
plans for their vulnerable communities
including nursing homes including those
who are disabled including those are in
prisons or who have working environments
that they may have a more likelihood to
spread the infection and combined with
that it's the secretaries office of
minority health will soon be awarding a
large contract to guarantee a national
network of state local and
community-based organizations to assure
that those underserved particularly
racial and ethnic minorities are linked
to the surfaces they need not only
testing but in care as well and with
that I'd like to hand it over to Brad
Smith who's the director of the Center
for Medicare and Medicaid innovation but
has really been the chief operating
officer to make all of this come
together
Brad Thank You Admiral I want to talk
through a little bit specifically the
work that we've been doing with the
states so as the Admiral mentioned over
the past few weeks we've been working
with each state to set a target for
their testing goal for me over the
series of a couple of different calls
we've aligned on what those goals are
and as the Admiral mentioned and the
president mentioned they add up to over
twelve point nine mm
in tests in the month of May for every
state this is greater than two percent
of their population in the entire state
being tested in May and for many states
it's a much higher number than that when
you compare this as the president
mentioned to South Korea South Korea is
actually below that 2% not for a month
but for their total test to date since
the start of the year and so our states
have come together to set really
ambitious goals that were excited to
support them in meeting if you go to the
next slide as I talked about last time
in the press briefing there are really
three parts to making sure that a test
can happen the first part is the
specimen collection supplies the second
part is the machines and the third part
are the lab supplies that the machines
need to run and what we've been working
to do is to make sure that each state
has all three of those parts to be able
to conduct a number of tests the first
part is the specimen collection supplies
the commercial market today is providing
a large number of these supplies are
ready to States and are ready to
hospitals but we wanted to ensure that
every state had more than what they
needed to be able to conduct a number of
tests they're aiming in May so what
we've done is we've purchased enough
tests to support the state testing goals
for May and June so we will be sending
more than twelve point nine million
swabs and over ten million media to the
States over the course of May and a
similar greater number over the course
of June in addition we have several
million in reserve so if states are able
to exceed their goal in the third and
fourth week of May we can provide them
even more slobs and transport media and
again this is in addition to what's
already available in the commercial
market if you go to the next slide there
are large numbers have been talked about
many times a large number of testing
machines across the country over 5,000
different machines that can conduct
these tests the key part is making sure
that the machines and that the labs have
enough supplies to run the machines
there will be in the month of May
commercially produced over 25 million
test kits which is either the PCR and
extraction kits or the cottages to be
able to support tests and in their
effort it states in their testing effort
and what we've been working to do with
each state is understand their total
goal and each of the manufacturers has
been a great partner with us and told us
how many tests they're shipping to each
lab in each state over the course of May
and what we know is that in the
forget the number of tests cos the state
is getting is greater than their testing
goal for the month of May in addition to
what the states have already purchased
there's over 7 million additional tests
that remain unpurchased the majority of
those from thermo Fisher which is the
most common machine in the country so we
feel very confident the states will not
only have the specimen collection
supplies and the machines but also the
extraction kits and the reagents they
need to be able to hit or potentially
exceed their testing goals if you go to
the last slide the last piece of the
puzzle is making sure that Americans
have access to these tests healthcare
providers hospitals primary care
physicians are already providing these
tests today and we for the past six or
seven weeks have been partnered with the
retailers who have massively been
ramping up their effort today there are
over 240 retail sites we've been working
with the retailer's to make sure that
they're specifically targeting
low-income and other vulnerable
communities across the country and we're
talking with them about potentially
opening more than another thousand
additional sites over the next month or
two so we hope that we've put together
the right pieces of the puzzle having
access points for patients and Americans
across the country having the specimen
collection supplies needed to take the
test
having the machines and then also having
the lab testing supplies with the
machines so thank you very much maybe
you'll both stay there could be some
questions okay John go ahead you can't
hear me we had a situation here at the
White House on Friday where a member of
the vice president's staff tested
positive for corona virus which is now
caused three of the top US officials
involved in the corona virus response to
self isolate two-part question where did
the system break down to allow that to
happen and where what would you say to
employers to look at the experience here
at the White House and say are we ready
for this I don't think the system broke
down at all in one person tested
positive surprisingly because the
previous day tested negative and three
people that were in contact relative
contact who I believe they've all tested
totally negative but they are going to
for a period of time self isolate so
that's not breaking down
it can happen it's the hidden enemy
remember that it's the hidden enemy so
things happen but the three tested
negative the one who tested positive
will be fine
it will be absolutely fine yeah well I
think you know we have a lot of people
in the white house and we had one
basically we had one person so we had a
lot of people that work here this
building is shocking if you looked at
the numbers and it's also tremendous
numbers of people coming in normally you
wouldn't do that
but because we're running a country we
want to keep our country running so we
have a lot of people coming in and out
many of those people most of those
people are tested depending on what
portion of the oval office area they're
going in everybody coming in to the
president's office gets tested and I
felt no vulnerability whatsoever agend
but the two people as I said and three
people are they have been tested and
it's negative and they'll be probably
out of quarantine very quickly I can
follow up on that your staff your senior
staff is you just referenced is able to
get tested every day when will it be
that Americans across the country will
to get tested every day as they go back
to work very soon I mean really very
soon it's an interesting question
because normally you would have said
that you are not tested and you would
have been you know knocking us for not
getting tested so if we get tested it's
a problem and if we don't get tested
it's a problem but I like the way your
question was phrased better this way
because it is a positive we are tested
we have great capability you look at all
of these machines here they're
incredible machines is that the best
anywhere in the world no place in the
world has this kind of equipment
other countries are calling
sophisticated countries and they're
calling lots of countries and we're
trying to make as much as we can
available to them because there's
nothing like what we've been able to do
in a literally a couple of months what
they've been able to do the private
sector what they how they got it done
this is a five to fifteen minute test as
an example the Abbott Laboratories test
these tests are highly sophisticated
gated very quick very good this is
things that didn't even exist a short
while ago so we do have a great testing
capability at the White House we're
doing it and I think generally speaking
we had a call with the governor's the
other day generally speaking without
exception they were all extremely happy
with what's going on with respect to
their testing okay what should people be
told to go back to work until they have
that assurance that they and their
co-workers are able to get that which
we're still not there we're leaving that
up to the governor's as you know and if
we see something wrong we'll call them
out and we'll stop it but we are leaving
it up to the governor's some are being
not aggressive enough in my opinion and
some are being a little bit aggressive
but they're being very careful and the
people of the country they've learned a
lot over the last two months they've
learned about social distancing and
washing your hands and other things that
we've all learned and talked about
they've learned about I see everybody
just about everybody has a face mask on
they've learned about face masks the
good and the bad by the way it's not a
one-sided thing believe it or not but
our country has learned our country has
been incredible and you see the numbers
they're dropping very substantially the
numbers are dropping around our country
very very substantially so we leave that
john up to the governors and i think
they're making a lot of good decisions
we've had as I said a great relationship
with governor's Democrat and Republican
and I think overall they're making very
good decisions
nobody in this group all the ones behind
the rope that's interesting please you
said in your comments earlier we have
met the moment we have prevailed to you
third is the mission accomplished even
with one point no we've prevailed on
testing is what I'm referring to that
was with regard to testing you never
prevail when you have ninety thousand
people a hundred thousand people when
you have 80 thousand people as of today
when you have this the kind of death
you're talking about when you have
potentially millions of people
throughout the world that are dying
that's not prevail what I'm talking
about is we have a great testing
capacity now it's getting even better
there's nobody close to us in the world
and we certainly have done a great job
on testing and testing is a big is a
very big important function by the way
some people consider it more important
than others to be honest with you but
testing certainly is a very important
function and we have prevailed we have
the best equipment anywhere in the world
okay please there are a variety of
reports that Chinese hackers are
attempting to steal technology related
to vaccine research is this something
you're concerned about what can you say
so what else is new
with China what else is doing tell me
I'm not happy with China they should
have stopped this at the source they
could have stopped it right at the
source so now you're telling me they're
hacking so I just say this Steve what
else is new watching it very closely if
I could follow up sir the South China
Morning Post the Beijing newspaper says
that China would like to reopen
negotiations on the trade deal to make
the terms more favorable to them is this
something you'd be interested in doing
no no not even a little bit no I'm not
interested we signed a deal I had heard
that too they'd like to reopen the trade
talk to make it a better deal for them
China has been taking advantage of the
United States for many many years for
decades because we had people at this
position right here where I'm standing
sitting right in that office the Oval
Office
allowed that to happen no I'm not
interested in that let's see if they
live up to the deal that they signed
okay please go ahead mr. president what
are your thoughts about a second round
of direct payments to Americans that's
included in the the house Democratic
view well we're talking about that with
a lot of different people I want to see
a payroll tax cut I want to see various
things that we want I want the workers
to be taken care of but we are talking
about that we're negotiating with the
Democrats we'll see what happens but as
I said it's a transition and it said
this is really going to be in my opinion
we'll see but I think it's going to be
something that's going to be very
special it's a transition to greatness
and greatness is next year right from
the beginning I think we're going to do
fantastically well I view the third
quarter as I said as a transition
quarter it could be pretty good but a
transition quarter toward the end of the
fourth quarter you're going to see some
numbers that are going to be tremendous
I think and next year you're going to
have potentially the kind of numbers
that you saw before and maybe even
better because there is a pent-up demand
that is you know a lot of people wanted
to do things they're ready to do things
and they've had to hold back because of
the virus so I think you're gonna have
with that pent up demand a phenomenal
year next year unless somebody messes it
up by coming along and raising taxes
doubling tripling quadrupling your taxes
like a certain party namely the
Democrats want to do you'll mess it all
up you know we had the greatest in the
world I presided this administration
presided over it it got great for a
reason and we'll do it again and we'll
do it again very quickly and very easily
I see that happening yes ma'am please
Thank You mr. president almost everyone
as you noted in the Rose Garden is
wearing a mass today why haven't you
required everyone at the White House to
wear mass before now well there are
certain distance from me or there a
certain distance from each other they do
in the case of me I'm not it I'm not
close to anybody I'd like to be close to
these two gentlemen they're hard-working
great men but they just said frankly
let's keep it this way so obviously in
my case I'm very far away from everyone
but if you look at all of those people
over there every one of them from what I
see these are White House staffers
they're White House representatives the
White House executives and everybody has
a mask on we've had just about everybody
I've seen today has worn a mask yep are
you the one who required that sir yeah I
did I did I required it yes please can
you get some figures on what you're
changing to ramp up testing wind will
that be a true statement exactly and how
exactly are you going to accomplish that
what's a true statement already we have
more testing than any country in the
world by far but I'll let Admiral go
into a little bit of the future when you
look at the testing numbers that we
worked with collaboratively with with
the state leadership it's not just with
the governor but the state health
officers the state epidemiologist the
public health labs it's really a
combination of testing those who need
something for diagnosis diagnostic
testing tracing so testing those who
have been around the people with a
diagnosis but the largest fraction of
that is really moving into surveillance
that is testing those who are
asymptomatic and when you do the numbers
this amount of testing on a state to
state basis really is in the range that
we need to accomplish all of that
certainly within the range that we need
so it really encompasses those three
things the other thing I would say is
particularly as we move into the summer
there are surveillance mechanisms and I
talked about them before like a weather
radar and just think about that weather
radar on the influenza-like illness
Network which is at about 75% of hot of
health care institutions and syndromic
surveillance so if we see a blip on that
weather radar combined with CDC
personnel and every single state and
with contact tracers we really run to
the fire right and that's when you
detect you trace and you shut off that
outbreak right when it starts seems to
be a double standard here mr. president
where members of your own staff can get
tests frequently when they need it but
ordinary Americans cannot so when will
the rest of America have the same access
that members of your own White House
have to testing and you know what if we
didn't get the tests if we did no tests
in the White House should be up
complaining why aren't you getting tests
for the White House see we can't win
because if we didn't get the test you'd
be up I understand you very well better
than you understand yourself and frankly
if we did get tests done you'd be up
complaining about the fact that we
didn't have the test said now that we're
doing so well on tests and so quick and
so fast
five minutes etc and so accurate you're
complaining that we're getting too many
tests so you can't win go ahead Phil
yeah mr. president many Americans want
to return to their normal lives but
they're afraid to do so how can you
ensure Americans that it's safe to go to
their own workplaces when the most
secure workplace in the country the
White House cannot contain the spread of
the corona virus it's infected some of
your own staff well when you say some so
we have a person and the person got
something happened right after a test
was done three other people met that
person came into relative contact very
little contact and their self
quarantining that is not exactly not
controlling it we I think we've
controlled it very well we have hundreds
and hundreds of people a day pouring
into the White House it's a massive
office complex including the very large
building right behind us that you know
so well so I think we're really doing a
very good job in in watching it and I
think it's very well contained actually
and part of the reason it is because of
all the tests were able to give but it
was one person and the other
but we're only people there quarantine
do you understand this Phil they're
quarantined for a specific reason the
reason is they were in the general
proximity of the one person and the one
person I believe will be fine in a very
short period of time it hasn't vice
president pence followed the CDC
guidelines of self isolation and and
other people who might have been exposed
well I'm gonna have to ask that he will
give you that information whatever he is
proceeding and doing he will give you
that information I'll make sure that
they put out a notice John go ahead
please mr. president up until now it's
thought that the most vulnerable people
were those above the age of 60 or 70 or
80 and the children were pretty much I
don't want to say immune from this but
weren't affected by it but all day long
in the news today we have been hearing
and seeing this terrible syndrome yeah
there's some 85 children have now three
of them have died what is the task force
talking about in terms of that and and
what could be done about yeah we're
seeing that all over the world now with
young children very very tiny percentage
but it's still it's the swelling and the
skin rash and we're looking at that very
closely John it's a phenomena that's
just been brought to everyone's
attention a couple of weeks ago and what
you may have something to say about that
so thank you for pointing that out and
again I've said many times I'm a
pediatrician and a pediatric ICU doctor
on this syndrome which we call or
similar to Kawasaki syndrome it has been
seen in a novel coronavirus before and
it's associated with illnesses so we
have a very strong activation on this we
do no treatments for this but the CDC is
act is interacting actively with the
pediatric intensive care unit network to
create case definitions and to
understand how this is going and if
their predispositions the National Heart
Lung and Blood Institute I spoke to dr.
Gary Gibbons who directs that who is
advancing many research projects based
on that the asper the assistant
secretary for preparedness and response
has a team out in several areas looking
at if there are any special treatments
we know what the basic treatment is but
this is a little bit different than we
elisee so there really is an activation
among all the branches within HHS
working with networks at children's
hospitals and ICU nets it is a small
percentage but it is quite frightening
and this reflects the fact that this
virus affects the vasculature we see
clotting we see strokes and this is a
vasculature phenomena of inflammation we
see in children with this newly emerging
syndrome now among young children what
do you say to parents who would like to
get their children back to school but
are now we're looking at this and
potentially afraid to do that well again
it's a tiny percentage but you're right
so we're looking into it very strongly
and the Admiral is he said he's known
about this for long before this happened
but it is a very very small percentage
and people recover from that the
children recover from that right yes sir
most do recover from this but it is a it
is a serious and it can be a fatal
condition so we do want to make sure
that parents understand that high fevers
red rashes particularly in your child
you may need to contact your health care
provider there are treatments for this
they work very effectively if if got
neroli at least for the vast majority of
the cases we're studying that very
closely and it's been on the radar for
weeks actually because we've seen this
for quite a while but it's been very
rare but we're we're looking at it very
closely it's very important to us I
think one of the things were most proud
of is this just came out deaths per
100,000 people death so deaths per
100,000 people Germany and the United
States are at the lowest rung of that
ladder meaning low is a positive not a
negative Germany the United States are
the two best in deaths per 100,000
people which frankly to me that's
perhaps the most important number there
is please go in the back please
thank you Thank You mr. president I have
a few questions one on about Avery
Payson one on the corona virus the first
on the corona virus to present the vice
president is said to be in some sort of
self isolating keeping his difference
from people what do you say to America
do say how can you how can you keep me
safe how can you reopen the government
if even the vice president itself
isolating and why hasn't testing gotten
up to the point where every American who
wants a test can get a test
well the vice president first of all has
been tested and he's negative and it was
tested yesterday tested today and he's
negative
he's a very good shape and I think that
that's going to be fine as far as
Americans getting a test they should all
be able to get a test right now if they
should be able to get a test that's the
problem with a question like that we go
through a whole announcement saying
we're number one in the world by far by
a factor of two and even three and four
depending on where you're looking and I
get a question when will everybody be
able to get tested if somebody wants to
be tested right now they'll be able to
be tested as far as the incident the
attorney I think it's horrible and it's
certainly being looked at by many people
I'm speaking to many people about it he
looked I saw the picture of him in his
tuxedo it was so beautiful I bet he
looks like a a wonderful young guy would
have been a wonderful I mean just a
wonderful guy I think it's a horrible
thing I think it's a horrible thing now
with that being said as you know they're
studying the case very carefully they're
interviewing everybody involved and
we'll see what happens to me it's a very
sad thing I spoke to a number of people
that are very much involved in it I've
been following that one very closely it
breaks your heart to watch it it breaks
your heart and certainly in the video
was a a terrible looking video to me but
you have a lot of people looking at it
and hopefully an answer is going to be
arrived at very quickly but it's
something that is heartbreaking question
about the case if I could ask it then
the specific question I have is you said
that there possibly are things that
happen that that were
recorded on the tape could you new its
expound on what you mean by that and
your thoughts on well I saw the tape and
when they moved left
I don't believe when they move left
outside of the tape nobody saw what was
going on nobody saw it's an empty spot
on the tape I guess now do they have
additional tapes I hope but I will say
that it's something that based on what I
saw doesn't look good somebody that I
have a lot of respect for is Senator
Scott of South Carolina you know who I'm
talking about he's a great gentleman
he's a great senator is a great
gentleman Tim Scott and I called him two
days ago I said Tim what do you think
tell me what do you think he's very
disturbed by it he's very disturbed and
I'm very disturbed also please go ahead
president Ron thank you I have two
questions when I'm testing and want on
democratic states that you tweeted about
first the money for this new testing
support today comes from the Care Act
cares Act which you signed into law 42
days ago did your delay and embracing
widespread testing have anything to do
with the desire to suppress the official
number of US cases and deaths as you try
to reopen the country no we just wanted
to make sure that we had the proper
machinery apparatus and everything else
out there before people started wasting
money so method of saving money we want
to make sure we had even things like
this plus they have machines that are
far more complex than this they have
massive machines that some of the
laboratories that can do millions of
tests we want to make sure everything
was in place okay
earlier today you tweeted the Democrats
are moving slowly for political purposes
why do you believe that their motive is
politics rather than public safety and
how do you respond to criticism that
you're also motivated by politics to try
to grow the economy ahead of the
election well I think that if you look
at Pennsylvania as an example if you
look at various other states I won't get
into them the people want to go back the
numbers are getting to a point where
they can and it just seems to be no
effort on certain blue states to get
back into gear and the people aren't
going to stand for it they want to get
back
they're not gonna stand for it they want
our country open I want our country open
too I want it open safely but I want it
open don't forget people are dying the
other round you can go with the enclosed
route everything's closed up you're in
your house you're not allowed to move
people are dying with that - you look at
drug addiction you look at suicides you
look at some of the things that are
taking place people are dying that way -
you could make the case it's in even
greater numbers so it's a it's a
situation that some people and I've
noticed that some states could be moving
more quickly and also at the same time
safety look safety is paramount but
people are dying in a lockdown position
- and everybody understands that they're
just starting to find out and look at
what's going on with drugs and look at
what's happening with suicides you know
please please go ahead
quarantine for several months now social
distancing yet we're still seeing about
20,000 new cases a day one to two
thousand deaths is there anything else
the administration is planning to do to
get these new cases under control
because we seem to be on a plateau
well excuse me there 20,000 the numbers
are way down from what they were two
weeks ago I mean the numbers are really
coming down and very substantially this
weekend was one of the lowest we've had
this is you know the numbers are coming
down very rapidly all throughout the
country by the way there may be one
exception but all throughout the country
the numbers are coming down rapidly
I think you see that Admiral now 130,000
cases that go through August is that do
you agree with those models is that your
expectation well the models haven't been
exactly accurate these are models done
by a lot of think tanks a lot of
universities you look at some of the
models have been way up a few of the
models have been accurate but as far as
the models are concerned if you go by
the model we were going to lose 2.2
million people and because we took we
mitigated we did things that were very
for our country to do frankly we had to
turn off our whole magnificent economy
we had to turn down the whole country
we're at the lowest of all of the models
I mean if you look at I guess that 120
100 to 120 thousand people would be at
the low side and we're at
there's nothing low look nothing low one
is too many people and I say it all the
time one person to lose for this is too
many people it's a disgrace what
happened but if you look at the models
we're at and alone at the lowest of
those projections but the models are not
models done necessarily by the white
house they're models done by many people
all over the world and if you take the
most respected of those people many of
those models are wrong I mean they've
been wrong as far as the u.s. is
concerned because those numbers are
nowhere near what was projected
potentially you know what I don't want
to think about it even I know that we're
doing everything we can we're doing a
good job we acted very early we acted
extremely early in keeping China out of
our country and banning people from
China coming in other than our citizens
which we obviously had to take and they
were quarantined or watch carefully they
were tested they will watch very
carefully but we had about 40,000 people
coming in from China from Asia and we
had to obviously take the people can you
imagine as I said you're a US citizen
we're not going to take you that doesn't
work so but they were very carefully I
was with Ron decentest he said they put
literally put the people that came in
from China in quarantine for a
substantial period of time know that was
a big decision I think we saved hundreds
of thousands of lives by acting very
early and when I did this I think the
Admiral can say it everybody was against
my doing it everybody everybody was the
professionals the doctors I was pretty
much by myself on that one and it was a
lucky thing we did it because we saved
hundreds of thousands of lives
yeah please good
Thank You mr. president earlier today
the vice president urged governor's to
have all their nursing home residents
tested why not just mandate that why not
require that have you considered that
well I would certainly consider that I
will mandate it if you'd like I would I
think it's important to do and I think
frankly some of the governor's were very
lacks with respect to nursing homes it
was obvious right from the beginning the
state of Washington where 26 or 28
people died very early on and I would
have said nursing homes and I did say
nursing homes that's what they should
now some of the states many of the
states are doing that but I think all of
the states should be they have the
capacity to do what they should be doing
nursing home that is a real
vulnerability the two staffers that were
announced last week as testing positive
are you aware of any additional White
House staff no not at all I'm only aware
of people that saw them were tested the
tests were negative and they're
quarantining anyway so please go ahead I
wanted to ask are you now or are you
considering separating some more with
Vice President Prince as a precautionary
measure well first of all the job he's
done on task force the job he's done
frankly as the vice president of the
United States has been outstanding and
he's a warrior too just like doctors and
nurses I mean he is working so hard and
he's coming into contact with a lot of
people but again he tested negative so
we have to understand that but he comes
into contact with a lot of people it's
something probably during this
quarantine period we'll probably talk
about I have not seen him since then but
I would say that he will he and I will
be talking about that yeah we could talk
on the phone if I could the president
just said that doctor foul Qi dr. Han
have tested negative then why do they
need to be isolated is there some
concern that they could be spreading the
virus in some
their concern about the testing why do
they need to ISIL so this is a very
fundamental concept and I'm so happy you
brought that up because it underlies a
lot of the questions here if you test
negative just at that one point that
just means you have tested negative for
that point in time we know that the
incubation period for this virus can be
many days so the CDC guidelines really
says that if you're in close contact
just testing negative on that one day
doesn't mean you won't be positive later
on so the prudent and the recommended
thing to do is to self isolate yourself
for the entire period of incubation and
really then some so that's what they're
doing it's a precautionary manner
because they were negative we all hope
that they remain negative but if they
turn positive in a day or two or became
symptomatic that's still possible even
with a negative test
mr. president and one of your mother's
day tweets you appear to accuse
president Obama of the biggest political
crime in American history by far those
were your words
what crime exactly are you accusing
President Obama of committing and do you
believe the Justice Department should
prosecute him Obama game it's been going
on for a long time it's been going on
from before I even got elected and it's
a disgrace that it happened and if you
look at what's gone on and if you look
at now all of this information that's
being released and from what I
understand that's only the beginning
some terrible things happened and it
should never be allowed to happen in our
country again and you'll be seeing
what's going on over the next over the
coming weeks but I wish you'd write
honestly about it but unfortunately you
choose not to do so yeah jumplist what
is the crime exactly thank you think you
know what the crime is the crime is very
obvious to everybody all you have to do
is read the newspapers except yours John
please get a clarification on the on the
testing we've seen clearly that the
numbers of tests of going up there been
some advancements in testing but you
said twice or today that every American
who wants a test can get a test yes
that's not the case 1.9 million tests
per day is far short of every American
that wants a test to be well I'm gonna
have the advil but I will say just from
listening and hearing like you do we all
do not everybody should get a test
because they have to have certain things
and they're gonna know when they're not
feeling right those are the people that
will be getting the tests but I don't
wanna let you take it from there please
so everybody who needs a test can get a
test we have plenty of tests for that
right right now in America anybody who
needs a test can get a test in America
with the numbers we have if you are
symptomatic with a respiratory illness
that is an indication for a test and you
can get a test if you need to be contact
raised you can get a test and we hope
and not hope we are starting to have a
symptomatic surveillance which is very
important again that's over three
million tests per week that is
sufficient for everyone who needs a test
symptomatic contact tracing and to our
best projections the ACM
maduk kind of surveillance we need to
get that and that that's the way it is
and remember um I I work at HHS
I work there every day I don't get
tested every day I get monitored for my
symptoms am i febrile do I have any
other symptoms I wear a mask when I go
in that's a safe work environment for
the environment we have if I became
symptomatic I would get a test and if it
were positive I would isolate and
there'd be contact tracing to stop that
just the way it was done here if I'm not
symptomatic I do the precautions as
everyone is recommended in phase one and
that's the essence of safety safely
opening America and John the numbers are
coming way down and they're coming down
rapidly and that's a beautiful thing to
see and that's pretty much universally
all across the country they're coming
down very rapidly so very important
please go ahead
so so Americans who are going back to
work
shouldn't expect and shouldn't need
shouldn't want to have the same thing
that people coming to work here at the
White House have which is the ability to
get tested regularly so let me clarify
as well people who come into close
contact with the president get tested on
a regular basis okay if I were not in
close contact with the president
specifically I would not get tested like
most people here do not get tested
that's a very specific circumstance when
I work at HHS I go at HHS I don't get
tested I do the exact thing that we ask
Americans to do to monitor your symptoms
if you were symptomatic
self isolate get tested Ward's what are
our community-based testing sites at
your hospitals they're even at-home
testing now that has been authorized and
and to cooperate that if you need to be
contact traced B contact trace and
cooperate with your local public health
but not everybody who walks in here gets
tested every time they do if you're
symptomatic here at HHS at a meatpacking
plant at a school you need to get tested
the meatpacking plants now we're doing
very well there's great testing around
those plants and we're finding out who
had the problem they're being
quarantined and the meat packing is
moving along very nicely but they were
they were trouble spots they were hot so
definitely please and you know one thing
I think it's very important that John
just to finish we have now and nobody
says it they just don't want to write it
by far more tests than any other country
in the world not even a contest and the
quality of our test is the best anywhere
in the world that's very important to
say please go ahead to make sure I
understand the White House's position
are you saying that right now you feel
there is enough testing how to put
testing across the United States or do
you feel that it needs to be ramped up
and by how much
if so we've been I think we've been
clear all along that we believe in the
data indicate we have enough testing to
do the phase one gradual early reopening
that has been supported in the in the
president's plan and the task force plan
and it has to be a phased reopening
nobody's saying turn the light switch on
and everyone go because then it would be
really impossible to control the spread
of the spread of the virus you know
there are many many models out there the
Rockefeller Foundation published as
their recommendations of about three
million tests per week that's exactly
what we're doing if you look at our
agent based models it's far below that
if you take the Safra Center at Harvard
and correct their Mis assumptions like
on the sensitivity of the test the
mitigation processes and how many people
get hospitalized you get about that
number now I am NOT going to come here
and say we can absolutely swear it's
God's truth that this is the number we
need but we know we have enough to open
and we're going to be very careful with
our ili net with our surveillance
programs and what the day to come in to
inform us even further as we grow and
learn I don't come to the White House to
work I either go to FEMA or I go to HHS
and let me just talk you through what
the protocols are there because I would
never get tested if I wasn't coming to
the White House so every day when we
come in we get our temperature taken and
we get asked question
about if we have symptoms if you don't
then you enter the workplace and then
there's hand sanitizer all over the
place in rooms that are made for
conference rooms they put pieces of
paper that say don't sit and essentially
every other every third seat to separate
people and so there's a lot of
precautions that we're taking in the
federal government that are separate
from testing and those are the
precautions that the agencies that
Admiral Gerar and I are working at every
day are using to let us continue working
if people want to get tested they get
tested we have the greatest capacity in
the world not even close if people want
to get tested they get tested but for
the most part they shouldn't want to get
tested there's no reason they feel good
they don't have sniffles they don't have
sore throats they don't have any problem
if they do feel there's something
happening they have the absolute easy in
fact Rhonda Santos of Florida the
governor's doing a fantastic job in
Florida he said he's got a little bit of
the opposite problem he's got so much
testing that people sit around and wait
for people to come in that they have far
a great over capacity for testing and
there are numerous other states that
have told me the same thing that's by
the way a good problem not a bad problem
okay
yeah go ahead please many times that the
u.s. is doing far better than any other
country when it comes to testing yes why
does that matter why is this a global
competition to you if everyday Americans
are still losing their lives and we're
still seeing more cases every day well
they're losing their lives everywhere in
the world and maybe that's a question
you should ask China
don't ask me has China that question
okay when you ask them that question you
may get a very unusual answer yes behind
you please sir why are you saying that
to me specifically I'm telling you I'm
not saying it specifically to anybody
I'm saying it to anybody that would ask
a nasty question like that please go
ahead okay anybody else please go ahead
in the back please okay next next place
I did and you didn't respond and now I'm
calling on the other lady in the back
please ladies and gentlemen thank you
very much appreciate it
thank you very much